doneghy we're gone we're wrong right now
just see I want I want people to see how
we talked it's kind of like you and I I
got a man with our legs crossed
yeah legs we do have our legs crossed we
kind of talked low sometimes you know
what I mean we sit by the coffee I sip
on this coffee just doing a little sip
you said the best coffee is it now it's
not can I get some color on those shoes
because I'm not mad at i'ma call the
Louis Vuitton oh these aren't for you
bro and I feel like I could pull those
off except me too
I don't know about the Louie I'm on the
side though the Owen says Vuitton but
the other ones called Thursday gift not
mad at them why would you be there like
a hunt on steroids
you're like cons if they would be toward
what what do you think about it is about
you and shoes because that's usually
usually traditionally a female obsession
right now there's a lot of shoe heads
out there yeah there's more now than
ever I think right that's like except do
you think that you're a giant man with
powerful body just big bones and strong
a lot of fast twitch muscle great
athlete we all know this but do you
think you have just an extra - is - just
a little more estrogen I don't think no
I mean just do you ever do you feel like
you think like a woman sometimes no see
I thought your chest see I think it's
weird guys who don't give a [ __ ] about
what they wear you know more than 600 of
these were given to me these are my
golden goose I was there when your
friend gave it yeah but but I mean black
business I ain't helping anyone
yeah I can't address for comfort and
utility oMG blur yeah you like you like
this there's no middle ground feel like
either someone's says you're dudes
they're really into fashion or they just
don't keep a [ __ ] right all and their
girl does the shopping I think I think
that the world is a better place and
like I understand people wanting to be a
little bit more into fashion
thank God it's easy to make fun of it
but we all we all in a way want to look
good right so my nephew's I bought them
- James purse shirts and they dressed
their young University but I bought them
these really nice they're expensive and
they look really good they wear those
shirts out that's that's a great shirt
jeans in that right so when you get it
and you get a shirt like that you go oh
that's why this costs sometimes
sometimes you can be like oh that's why
this costs a hundred Oh red muffler yeah
yeah yeah this big pipe yeah better
that's everywhere like I was at the
Grove this weekend and literally going
the shops and just playing to
colored softies that's like the that's
like thing what does she do this weekend
you were gone right I was in Utah with
my son
Buda my jaw and my paw two other boys
really o'clock played real Kali [ __ ]
they're real caught real [ __ ] fest my
mom my mother kind of mattering around
kind of like you know taking care of the
kid doing what mom my mom is a
traditional Italian woman so she's doing
all the town traditional things like
cooking giving us [ __ ]
nope see that way it doesn't do that I
know value you say traditional in the
kitchen yeah then why I told you my
parents been married like 100 years
seven hundred years over each other oh
oh oh we're not just when your father
breeze does it gets on your mom's murder
sir it is 100% and sir if I may I have
to say this my dad hides from her in the
house he's trying to get rid like I
caught him behind the site oh that's
where are you and I hear movement is she
around big bill dude he still does that
now couple things about my part 76 a lot
of time on his hands you understand so
Golf is one time I went and played some
golf with a professional just play
something on the tour for a while it's
saying when you got a guy that good and
teaches you a couple things you know hit
the ball pretty well yeah blah blah blah
so golf is his thing but he's taking up
the guitar my talent
now this is some older guys doing lots
up my dad took up the bomb did he know
the balls they got to start a band do
you and your dad only get that your dad
may have fun hey Melanie Hall & Oates
John Harvin Callan Tori I can see tease
now I can market the [ __ ] you'll hear
two old birds my dad though you've seen
how thick his fingers are he's got big
old
Wisconsin fingers you just used the to
use a giant [ __ ] base as a regular
guitar I look like a violin and a say
look look we're all made for certain
things now if I said I can't even I was
very serious and you said what are you
doing I was on all fours I was all fours
and I was running into like a sled
you're like we're doing I go practicing
becoming a nose guard yeah it's not for
you you would go variety and they gotta
have talked yeah I'm gonna make that
analogy with my father and that
strengthens me I'm telling you right now
I looked at my go it's an old Woody
Allen joke I go why don't you just buy a
parrot and strangle it because I'd
rather listen to that
why don't you saw a trumpet in half just
as big old [ __ ] corn dogs fingers he
has one string to be a zero rhythm
zero ear for music zero and it's just
not what his skills like I can do that
King King King King I was like I gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here would you come
back oh and your dad just Connecticut on
genna's just in man nope not for him not
for him with those long finger Hanson in
lingerie a mess though not 80s I'm an
aquatic like the British Arizona that
point into sand man Oh into a lie mom's
kids around - hey hey bro come on that's
why you sounds party I don't man
well [ __ ] my dad yelled on the tube or
the [ __ ] you know uncle on goes I went
the father lasted internment I came in
and he goes I'm taking Bongo license on
it
ah like the the drums you see the
Aborigines using and he goes yeah
exactly everything I went out of all the
instruments right you picked the bongos
dude - what was that something he's
always wanted I have no idea picture
himself in a Hawaiian shirt with shorts
just hey my bad Canessa
everybody come on man hey you tried
talking about a shop on the [ __ ] ball
you thinking you know that uh Paul Simon
you can elaborate on kappa yes everyone
South African years for that I think
that's what inspired my father I
he didn't tell me that I just assumed
that the problem is is uh I pretend I
didn't hear it he told me all summer
very cool
hey uh how's the weather in Denver I'm
not trying to help um don't keep moving
forward I'd be moving forward Jesus man
I wanted to make fun of the drunk guitar
my father stopped me and he goes you got
a problem that like he got defensive and
I went I don't I sure don't I don't good
for him though I think the
car and I think golf are good things and
watching documentaries on big cats are
great it could be worse he could go full
a wall turn into Caitlyn Jenner imagine
a death like listen I like to play the
guitar and I come off my date I've never
met anyone I've never met anybody with
less feminine energy both his parents
were men I think I'm telling you man
I've got yeah
there's no feminine energy he's not the
symptom doesn't give a [ __ ] you haven't
seen it I've seen that baby five times
my life could get I walking away what's
on the scone he could give hey man yeah
no police acknowledged me less I'm not
gonna help around here that's the jerk
man yeah whatever friend of Brian yeah
ah why I'm reading hey did you you text
about the ward coab website did you you
gotta watch him you told you just watch
it on his giant on his giant TV your
Papa wonder what to do or no he just go
he watched me yeah like boxing he'll
he'll watch boxing he's a football
basketball guy baseball guy and I love a
huge fan of that but but he'll watch
boxing but you know I was so excited
about that fight it was a good fight
well I have a question and I knew your
punch you see the undercard though the
homeboy that was really in it yeah so
that was so ringing that was amazing I
don't know if you were watching me go
watch highlights of rigging that it's
ridiculous first of all that nobody
butchers his name or their rig on diao
and rigging me out and it's riggan doubt
they say recognize it's pronounce it he
got do in French but it doesn't matter
the point is if you watch his highlight
reel if you see this however yeah it's
crazy he's just like this [ __ ] Magic
Man is good but um but I you could
clearly hear about gay and then they
were both swinging at the same time
they're both swinging in so Roy Jones
jr. point was well they're both swingin
- you're defending yourself at all time
but I mean you first thought he was
holding his head tell me tell me what
you think oldest said so I felt like
there were two illegal hints hits and
then bail any any knocks him out but
this might be another homeboy was thrown
to because his ray Atlanta is precise
the other guy didn't get knocked out so
how can you should they both be
disqualified that was kind of way
because his lands so should have been an
oak on
test what was very weird was after he
talked to the president at Letta
Commission he came back and said I'm
climbing as a knockout because you were
knocked out at or before the bell yeah
but you know why nonsense because but
the only reason they said this because
the head--it Commission the truck told
him and they actually went back and
looked at the tape right he got
misinformation because they're like nope
it's clear as day it was before the
punch was thrown before the bell so that
guy didn't see the whole time so he goes
you're sure they go clear as day so as
far as it goes in it's a knockout but as
like maybe a minute later Jim Lampley is
interviewing them talks Tillman goes so
we just got word that you were misguided
that's not the case
we're positive is after the belt as well
in that case we'll look at it and it
will be ruled you know no contest all
right oh yeah disqualifications
qualification at your law school which
it should i I don't think that guy was
knocked out I think that guy was playing
the role and if anyone I've been knocked
out of no one's ever been contesting
like that that's typically not the way
the body moves when you're not a job 220
when you the way he sat himself down and
then played the role that I think he was
looking for DQ or some sort of leniency
there so that he [ __ ] himself with
that but Roy Jones jr. hinted at that
you know he kinda yeah he hinted at it
he said you know it's very interesting
that these guys will be good luck out
yeah get it back down but then they're
just fine it right it right after
doesn't work like very interesting he
was like well I think only judgment I
suspected that and that's just a veteran
move probably a calculation that we're
not really not really it's not really
veteran is is I don't know what was
going on there I guess because they're
gonna stop the fight the way I look at
it since they were both throwing at the
same time um and it was definitely after
the bell I would have call it a no
contest me to write it again you know it
was every hour we can say we've knocked
out or not yeah let's say you was she'd
be in no time now here's their boss
thrown at the same time do you see a
chin yeah he put the way through his his
hands back after yeah that's not real so
uh yeah everyone was with him he sat
it's actually a shitty acting but yeah
he sat down almost he sat down but his
every like his body didn't shut down
like your brain turned literally turns
it the body off that wasn't a turn-on
any like your nasal oh my god
come on yeah yeah now though I'm going
to do my leg you had assessment tell me
what you think so I felt like
Kovalev was ahead for to two by round
six I think he handily won round six
Kovalev then in round 7 I started to
watch
I felt like Ward started to figure
Kovalev out a little bit but Cullen is
very rugged : looked tired he looked
like he wasn't as conditioned for
whatever reason or maybe nerves whatever
was theirs yeah I don't know
he was breathing like what this is going
to sound weird too when they when they
met in the center of the Ring I looked
at Kovalev stomach and his stomach he
was breathing rapidly it was really
weird I was like Matt you know whatever
that is I don't know if that was nerves
or whatever but so either way I felt
like Kovalev had that was was inflicting
most of the damage and also kind of
press in the fight so when I had him win
Tove live up on 3rd yeah by set round 7
now then I started to watch what I
looked like Andre Ward was not only
figuring them out but I saw a lot of
those punches that were that kovalev was
kind of going over a doubling over they
looked like they were right on the belt
and I've never been punched their boxing
wise so I don't know you would know
better it's still legal it's still legal
it's legal
ok on the belt right so for what the
ones at the end the moon that you can't
you can't fall under words he can't see
the right and Koblenz bent over yes but
I also think so so finally what I think
happened was this
I believe that anger was a better boxer
at the end of the day and I think he
proved it not only with that right hand
which hurt Kovalev but then went to the
body and kept going to the body and if
you look at those shots I do not believe
that those shots were in the balls or
low enough for Kovalev to claim that it
was you know I was in capacity yeah
where they shouldn't I think he got I
think he got hurt and I think he was I
just think he was looking for a way out
so I had so I scored it round by round
because last was so close I had to go
back and watch it several times so this
one I went round by round I had Kovalev
up I think either at war or kovalev up
just one round but Jim and the guy
calendar calendar
no no letter anymore was so off because
the issue is is Kovalev came out set a
higher pace and he sat in the to a lot
of more answers yeah which is why he was
more tired but also on tray warts at a
higher pace and he's more calculated
with this shot he knit throw as many and
landed damn they're just as many power
punches but he's not a power puncher so
a lot of those rounds Ward got the
better shots but Cola is such a power
puncher it looks more effective but Ward
was actually winning those we chose 15
item thinking more damage with those
jabs and all that you mean because
Ward's mobile have landed more jazz but
well they say copy Bach said he landed a
lot more shots my prop six he landed
more don't care about it I don't care
about that stuff the issue is the
quality of those landing like Kovalev
prilae through 600 more punches and ward
but if you look at the percentage of
what lands and what's important what
land that's what matters the style
doesn't mean you won the fight right so
copy strikes is a style thing so when
Jim Lampley and would touch on this and
move on when Jim Lampley goes oh I
actually watched you got the common
strike numbers on Conor McGregor's last
three fights he's not that active of a
fighters even big bigger mismatch then I
thought that that doesn't work Jim you
got to be educated on what's going on
mixed martial arts you can't have a
fighter with the same production and
output of a boxing match to MMA so when
he says that stuff just showed he's on
edge kid and I when you look at contract
numbers if those are geared towards the
guys fighting style if they both have
the same style like a Canelo triple gene
yeah how look eight copies yeah but I
like Floyd white well there was one shot
throws one guy look at wolf boy has a
high output but still you get a guy like
Floyd or you look at a guy like one with
chenko who's crazy output and finally
got that then they makes it but in this
fight you know Andre Ward is more savvy
I didn't I thought they're borderline
low but I also I've never seen ever in
my life a Russian turned his back I was
crazy ever in my life yeah
rarely turn back Nouveau defend yourself
know what always breaking is how what
one I think I think
mentally conditioning you know because
last night you he got out class up the
fifth round can be gassed out yeah so I
think that fifth round mentally just
trigger in his head oh my god
tired now so he's [ __ ] from there it
did he looked I don't think he was out
of shape he just set such a high pace
but Andre Ward went I mean he's best at
adjustments he's right you want to set
that high pace I'm doing the exact same
thing let's see who outpaces each other
yeah you're the one with the cardio
issue so then he just started taking
over we see Kobe left break I've never
seen a Russian break every mile I amazed
the first time I've ever seen a guy
break I thought you can already some of
those shots were low doable if you don't
think trouble has been hit there before
yeah I've never seen a break like that
but I think I had Ward either up one
round or Kobler but it was close he's
teetering back and forth but right you
know you can't argue that fight and to
be honest those two are never going to
fight again now and now we're gonna see
that fight yet I think we're deleting
one that rooty is a better fighter I
mean in Canada that first fight was up
in the air I thought Cole he coulda gave
it to Cove Lev benign Phi the second
time you stop them be a [ __ ] TKO Sal
you hittin that however gonna happen to
gank down the rows do you think then
Ward goes all find out heavyweight I'd
love to see mine even coach goes I'd
look to my his chance against Joshua
never stop stop
I'd have to find out how much Ward
weighs in it deal wise it'd be very
tough for Joshua to hit a guy like Ward
Ward is an absolute tech but yes but but
you know you're talking about a hundred
pound difference or something crazy no
no no no it wouldn't go any fight a 170
I am through with Joshua is how much -
forty to forty your board walks around
at 200 you about 45 different modern
yeah ladies of ease yeah I think Anthony
Joshua is too big a man he could do I
mean but you say that like Evander
Holyfield against Lex Lewis or these
other guys he's a he's an underworld is
a [ __ ] great fighter he really is the
eight 160 what's what he fought at right
and then automatic that light
heavyweight 249 odd yeah it's impede six
you should be much smaller frame yeah
that's a different huge yeah you don't
wanna fight those guys are too big
they're just too big it's a physics
issue I think but um God make six seven
say that but there's been god there's
been smaller guys you know yeah I feel
like maybe but I just feel like
when you get into the six seven range
six it's just it's just a difference
it's a litter there's the reason there's
weight classes that's crazy
um but he was going to do it be if
anyone if anyone it would be more Skills
than any heavy hitters I believe that
he's an amazing I would watch it too you
gotta miss number you're number two
pound for pound you guys forgot Loma
chenkov number one but resume why is all
good ones number one but just potential
skill technique I got LUMO Janko um yeah
what's his name under what just not you
know just not a drawl like neither cream
worth the couple ever draw that's best
there is yeah well they had they had
some animosity I don't know how much of
that was theatrical or not but yeah
they're not that it's not theatrical
though they keep you know the history
but those guys that's that's all real
yeah not that doesn't draw you to the
fight oh there's not a very good loser
he was not very pleased upset yeah but
he you know I wish he hadn't talked
about the low blows and stuff because I
felt like some of that was imagining a
world title fight Brian baseball your
life and you feel against a way to lose
and got little he got low but he feels
like he was cheated so the first I
disagree with that so you look at Cova
the first fight his team 100% thinks
they want to get younger I can make it I
can see that argument so then the second
fight yet generally thinks he got low
blowed and cheated to get genuine think
he was low blowed or was that an excuse
to when he turned its back or was that
anxious because he broke because he
expanded his I think it's a book oh man
I hope I think it's cardio made a maybe
melee alkylate and then he also got what
he thinks low blow so I think I mean
looking by excuses yeah because I
watched those low blows especially the
ones he liked the ones were really kind
of like how to breather right on the
belt I mean you know you see we can't
say I watch those low blows and they're
legal because we can't see him unless
you have an I did because I saw the
autumn slow motion no no I did too i
watch the same flat but you can't say
like please mama
during the fight I'm not talking about
during the final talk about the ones
where they stop it yeah we can't see
those because Koblenz bento and I did
see them I mean I'm from my angle when I
saw like especially what to be the more
iam the one they hit him right in the
belt right on that
like above the belt and that and that
that there was one where he hit him like
that and he kind of went down here let's
see this and I was like mmmm see this is
where this is the end of the fight so
let's watch this
so that would be below the belt but that
worry that's not as I feel like that's
his pubic bone at the most like it's not
as balls right
we don't know cuz what we use in the way
I'm looking so that would so this is the
belt line here be yeah okay so according
to that the viewed we're seeing there
that'd be a low blow
I don't really went over here though
right so what what happened here and
then I don't know I don't know they
finish the fight so how you can say
they're not you know I'm say like that's
fair to say that well because the blows
that I saw looked like the blows that he
was claiming over that one during the
fight that that ad to me was borderline
that's what it looked like to me you
know I mean it did look like it was
close to his balls which is the main
issue right but we don't know where is
it balls in that picture you know yeah
but you can't say these letting let's
see like certain like so they had a
great angle of this is what everyone saw
okay that's a different thing this is
the brilliant so the end your time out
the angle I'll talk about there in
advance I'm not during the fight this is
the only angle anyone saw be yeah this
is it
yeah unless you had a special TV or I'm
not sure my angles that's he right there
right there right there that feels like
it's right on the belt you see that he
hit the B but watch tried again tried
again this here ready
boom-boom-boom-boom
I feel like it's above the bead you look
at that right there well no he's coming
lucky B I got that I to me that's not
below borderline or like it's borderline
I'll give it to you it's borderline and
and you know he's going down like that
but I feel like that's because he was
hurt and tired not so much because I'm
sure it's all above yeah I don't think
it's fair to say it's just because the I
think I world won the fight because he
calculated correctly I think that I
think that on Sergey Kovalev over
calculator are miscalculated he punched
himself out essentially he was more
tired
and I think Ward is just a smarter fight
I think Ward would have won the fight
regardless I don't I don't think we can
say you know those weren't luck that's
it's tough it's right there because
because there was one very clear punch
where
in the middle of fight or Kovalev went
down yeah but you and with Roy Jones jr.
saying that's illegal blow because you
could see it was clearly actually a
little bit above the belt line and so
that's when I when I went well that's so
in the middle of fight when I saw that I
was like that suspect to me that Kovalev
is going down because I felt like he was
using that as an excuse to be tired and
get his breath that's what it may be so
I then I'm here to say all those are all
legal though no no I think a lot of that
but I don't think in fault ward either
because he can't see there either and
Koval has bent over right he's upright
you can have way more body mass to work
with and be more calculated it stuffed
up though those that's bored and I like
if when they show the Commission
Commission there's gonna be a little bit
of you know tons my my feeling also and
what in telling we think of this if they
fought again three more times
I feel like words the kind of guy that
has got such a high fight IQ that he
figures you out yeah they're never fun I
think he would win again yeah Co
Blessington yeah yeah I'll never see
that fun I mean unless they overturn
that for some weird reason which you
know who knows in Boston if they did
yeah they shouldn't right but who knows
I don't know what's next I mean there's
nothing at light-heavyweight
there's nothing not much going on there
at all so I don't know what's next
forward that's why I think he did say
you know a fight at heavyweight go up
cruiserweight there's nothing cruiser
you know who's a cruiser I would I think
even bring up top tenet cruiser but not
just there's not a lot of huge marquee
fights for him right that was the one
you know it almost been better for the
sport not better for board if they
woulda you know if it'd been a
controversial decision went to coalesce
so they had to fight a third time did
you watch the Holly Holm [ __ ] Korea
fight yes that's a very timid fight
until she got knocked out
these rankings are so strange it was
this ideal don't know any idea top 100
and this is cruiserweight two hundo
there you go
name one guy you'd want to see him fight
there just give me one just like throw a
name out don't know anyway that's boxing
right now at that you know these upper
divisions suffer heavy weight very tough
it's nothing for him that I don't see
him fighting any of those guys
Tony belly Oh would be fun stay I don't
see him fight me mean these guys belly
oh nothing crazy yeah uh yeah I watched
uh Holly bad she was I call it to a tee
but the thing is it that was tailor-made
for two they need her to fight at 45 mm
just sideboards fighting them Megan
Anderson now right so and that's four
vacant title so they need someone to
fight Holly I mean some of the fight
cyborg well how he just seems so timid
every nook so she's counter puncher yeah
she got we not catch it the [ __ ] out
look what happens when she fights girls
who come forward oh yeah girls who come
forward and want to sit and play like
games we yeah Ronda hurt me they get
murked yeah like you know that's just
her biggest issues all has always been
her grappling a lot of that other stuff
you know but I damned that she need to
win she need that one jab and she knew
that when I see another one the stakes
were high I did not hate it that's
unjust decision yeah
[ __ ] clear this is bad
you seen this red bee oh yeah but why is
she taunting her and bringing her I
don't know why she was doing that either
she puts her hands down here she's like
telling me come and get it let me get it
and then Holly times are right boom
question mark ticked Oh God out out die
damn Holly needed that it's good for the
sport she did that to be honest that
division needs her so bad zone so bad um
man I would this weekend on Netflix I
watched I watched two really good things
I let's just dock called um
the keepers know we are monsters it's
about it's a brand new dock that's out
it's something monsters you see it if
I'm the trending or newest whatever and
it's about these juveniles who committed
horrible murders and they're going
through trial but documentary maker
comes in and these kids are willing to
be tried and he goes I'm a screenwriter
who's you know and so how many people in
this detention center that basically
jail want to be a screenwriter like
these four just terrible kids like yeah
I'd love to do have a future doing that
so he sits him down there and goes let's
throw out ideas and the way he got them
to tell that cos hurt you know they know
let's tell the story to the restaurant
trial the way he got them tellers story
is by doing scenes for screenwriting Wow
you know in but it was for character so
they can't get in trouble the court of
law if this is a made-up character so
you'd say like a kid would go the guy
would go so what would the mom do in
this situation he go well my feet always
go the kids real my friend's mom you
know she's never around she's on crying
they would tell their stories through
that and then they actually would
demonstrate the the at the play that
they did like what they shot but here
these kids stories and you're like oh my
this is so intense and these kids are
young there it is we are monsters and
you asked you like damn this is horrible
whole don't hear what the kids did I
never let them out everything bad [ __ ]
ever like what do they do well one kid
his he's always trying to one-up his
brother he's from he's else out he's
from El Salvador
he stopped Dorgan and he
is always trying to one-up his brother
his brother isn't gang and his brother
shot and killed two people because well
I got one up my brother so he decide
take a knife and at 13 and initially
stabbed two people and murdered them and
but he didn't get caught doing that and
then three years later he's 16 he had a
problem with a gang member so in Hancock
Park he decided to while the guy was
sitting on the bench group and shooting
back of the head several times and he
got away
yeah and then then there's a another kid
who comes from a good family he's this
white Mexican kid I can't tell what he
is really but he's just like kid and he
he just started into gangs and for
whatever reason pulled up next to this
car with a shotgun and said you're gonna
die dad a [ __ ] shot this girl several
times and I didn't kill her but shot her
through the liver the lung and in the
spine and she's paralyzed for the rest
of her life
now who was she some random person cuz
you want to show his friends he's hard
oh my god did you watch this but they
don't tell you these stories to like
later cuz they're telling the story like
oh my god how can we help man here and
they show you know the California
government voting on that because
there's a new rule that they pass
actually that let's say you get 30 to
life after 15 years you have possibility
of parole if you're juvederm if you're
13 to 17 your brain by different by then
that's that's their argument
yeah but I got man I got it'll be honest
you want students kids only I do not
want them on the street man there's a
lot of youth a lot of studies on on when
kids grew up in really violent
atmospheres or poverty or stuff and
Rogan had a guy named I think his
blobski
on he wrote a book called behave and he
they were talking about how when you
come up under stressful situations like
really bad poverty or neglect and stuff
children your frontal cortex of your
brain the frontal cortex doesn't develop
to the level and the same yeah and in
fact it never does but they talked about
this in this doggy if the thing is is so
so well
crimes a crime correct like you murdered
my sentence that person this innocent
girl
paralyzed for so absurd so you know how
many he got 180 years in prison yeah 180
years the one kid uh shot someone I
think he killed but he got out he got
like three years and he got out and he
goes back to the the filmmaker just to
talk to the guy yeah and the kids
dealing you know keep dealing math and
he's on man he's on coke you know he's
doing smoking PCP like he's just real
[ __ ] up but then you watch it and he
goes back home he lives with his mom his
aunts there it's a size of this studio
so one bedroom there's four beds they
have no money she was homeless so it's
like what the a lot but it's a defense
where Pete he defends her for these kids
and their last time I talked to him he
was he was like yeah I got a defend this
can I see what he did is he shot a kid
over his bike killed a kid and took his
bike and I was like a high independent
because I'm not I mean I'm gonna do the
best I can
they're saying this they always take
plea deals because like if you want to
go through the jury I'm gonna be super
[ __ ] this is what you look at when he
takes plea deal and she's like 15 years
13 years you do they help date kind of
help you out if you take the plea deal
yeah it's the people that goes oh we're
going to do it and you're so [ __ ] so a
lot of society's always like had this
sort of idea
and traditionally why do they have a
draft why did they have mandatory
military service well the idea was to
take young men and get them first of all
from 14 to whatever a 17 you get them
there's always that saying that guy said
if we incarcerated every
fourteen-year-old started got him in
some kind of a car incarcerated
situation whether it's military order
until they were 21 we have no crime you
know we'd have none of these things
young men do crazy things and so a lot
of times the idea behind the draft was
always in societies get these young
crazy boys do have crazy energy give us
something to do and by the time they're
done by the time they're 21 doesn't you
put them out there they like you learn
how to [ __ ] behave where to place
your energy and the military does that
for you so it people talk about this
last times that sort of the unorthodox
like you want to solve your crime
problem [ __ ] bring back the mansoor
draft at least I wonder I wonder if two
years of military service like the
Israelis have or so a lot of countries
have I wonder what that would do
to our society you know a mandatory
travel you no matter who you are you got
to go through the discipline of being a
soldiers in Korea like that house
Korea's each other you're doing well
they're great killing it killing it
killing it
yeah South Korea is very powerful and
everyone has to go even celebrity
everyone oh yeah the UFC fighters who
else does mandatory this country or this
country had a mandatory draft I mean for
up until yeah homicidal isn't most of
the draft you know it's funny how if you
look at this card like this country had
a draft all the way through Vietnam but
what countries still do who are like
powerhouses
ah well Israel has a mandatory draft
everybody does are they older world
power house though no but but I mean
it's Farley more argue goes for a
manotaur now I'm saying the countries
that don't have it I feel like are the
are kind of leading the way aren't they
um think about no I think this is a new
thing in liberal democracies the idea
that voluntary army might be just as
effective or more effective than a
conscripted army so we stopped in these
three places Vietnam Muslim Yan toyed
yeah so you know um I don't know what
conscription I don't know what countries
have but I know a lot of countries
military the answer I feel there's a lot
of things you can do besides enlisting
military job works might do it for you
yeah there's a lot it definitely good
for you a lot of well say you're forced
to yeah the military what the idea would
be the military kind of brings in all
those kids that basically either the old
story with this I mean like you're back
in the day the judge would say you got a
choice you can either you can either go
to jail or go to the military young man
right and you did a lot of that there's
always a lot of that in this country I
don't know about other countries I'm
sure to you I was watching I was
watching this [ __ ] thing where you
know now not like serious murders but
because the right under them you think
when you get sentenced to prison or jail
they have these upper estarán prisons
and jail systems so in Seal Beach
there's one like there's one right here
where they're fancy we get in front
white come on 202 it's just my hey check
it out so it's $220 a night I stay there
and you get
TV the beds are softer yet all the
snacks you want pay-per-view left it's
just like the hotel it's $220 and that
guy you know thinking I wonder if I
could I just wanna stay at night I want
to feel pretty my guy you know who it is
later you know well he spent so he got a
DUI again you got I think it's third DUI
you going jail we go to jail and they
gave him that option and he paid for it
and he went to $220 a night and then he
showed this lady can got to sexually
assaulted and she's like a little [ __ ]
staying in there don't I'm staying there
like he has money like what do you want
us to do like it's one of the options
horrible man a private businesses oh
I'll take that [ __ ] over State
Penitentiary I'll go where I got I'll
join a gang I'll go broke broke bro I'm
only 20 I like me out rate by the homies
I'll go broke staying at the [ __ ]
four seasons strengthened I've been
whatever it takes a I tell my wife
listen get yourself some fake titties
start to do the tricks daddy needs a
soft [ __ ] bed you guys need to watch
that I had a big weekend when I could
just chill and watch some that stuff I
saw you uh seen cold-case files another
old cold case yeah they brought it back
it's so good amazing stuff on that did
put it get sucked into that bull this
cold case one they showed this girl she
was 16 some small town like [ __ ]
Kentucky sound like that straight
[ __ ] the sticks she's 16 she goes
missed the her parents and so her her
dad mom leave for work she's getting
ready to go to school
dawn ends up missing they look at her
cell phone this is night this is 1999
night not that Fargo usually don't cool
case they're old school so but so 99 the
hooks on her phone the text
she went to doe dial 911 she write two
nine one and it's over she goes missing
they don't know where to find her
they're searching everywhere it's a
small town there's like two cops
searching her
can't find her the dad's brother her
uncle come he's like what's going on
there the searchin searchin and then
uncle gets sick he starts throwing up
and I click the [ __ ] so they quit
looking for that night they keep going
they can't figure it out they think it's
the neighbor to neighbors kind of weird
and you while you watch it
you are like it's the [ __ ] neighbor
[ __ ] this guy Michelle Bachelet
in the courtroom and he had an issue
with her and actually found a picture of
her in his room here I thought [ __ ] that
guy catch that [ __ ] 10 years or 15
years go by
huh boy and then they figured they'd tie
forget how she fit she fit she figured
out through the you know the advancement
of Technology stuff like that with the
DNA hanshan they found in this [ __ ]
just so the person that took her took
her for three days and tortured her
raped her cut her fingers off and then
killed her and they found the body like
in the lake right horrible [ __ ] so
horrible right so they found out that
the guy doing all this kept her in this
like barn so the the detective that
picked the case up like well who the
[ __ ] where is this barn like no one can
ever find it and then she was talking to
an old witness and the witness goes yeah
the kids used to party down here there's
this big tree down there and this this
dude who was in prison so he'd be a
foreman he's other sort of informant
informant and it conform it goes hey I
was I was basically Shawshank it was
like hey I was sacked up with this dude
in the in the slammer he says he
murdered that girl you guys can't solve
so he goes in he says the the evidence
is under this tree so I put two together
they find what the kids probably the
tree they find it was from her bed like
this closing in bed turns out it was her
uncle raping and molesting her since she
was age of six she got a real boyfriend
Dunkel knew when the dad was going to
leave so he came over to be like hey you
can't see the students should know
punched her broke her jaw then took her
and tortured and killed her and she was
acting like you searching for your own
brother so check this out so while
they're looking for the body they were
getting close he pretended he was sick
started stop making fun well guys I got
I'm sorry let's sit in there like [ __ ]
we better come around if you're that
sick he's a GI Willis tomorrow
what a psycho so that so then secure top
so six other girls come out and we're
like yeah he raped me too and molested
me six other girls he only got 15 years
there's a plea deal I want a moment it
gets a few interviews a dad
yes I don't you [ __ ] blood or not he'll
get out in 2021 I'll be waiting right
onions I'll be waiting
yeah you [ __ ] will be it was so heavy
man it was so heavy I want to make it
out on balls people to take this stuff
man oh man I do it on my watch so
there's this they're gonna call my mom
why she what happened there's this new
documentary called keepers yeah yeah and
and here's the thing that I've watched
the first episode and they're all
talking about it none an ex-nun she was
an excellent and she was killed but it
was 1969 I know and you know if you were
really old song I'm like it's a long
time ago I'm a little bored whoo oh my
god you know that's 1960 nice um Donald
trying to tell ratios you need to watch
the keepers and when you do get ready it
goes in so deep you know I'm secured
even talked about it yeah my shot go
check this [ __ ] out
I turned out for self so like hmm well
we're here it's all black and white are
you thinking I don't give a ah this is
so old you guys are just now coming up
killers probably long dead or something
on my on my job I mean goddamn documents
on the Zodiac killer sonship yeah you're
that [ __ ] uncle though what an evil
evil man they're evil people in 15 years
I have no idea torturing killing a girl
hemming and raping each other you should
be burned at the stake but yeah you
should it's just not I can't be driving
more evil have you seen that movie split
yes I don't know why it reminded me of
that a little bit I don't want kids well
it's been out for heaven a spoiler split
is a guy with multiple personalities yes
takes three girls and keeps them kidnaps
them and one of those girls had an uncle
that reminded me oh that's right there
you go that's the connection for saying
I thought you're leeching man I'm nice
right there's an uncle there man
yeah that's a different game I was
talking about this yesterday it's a
family barbecue if you have a daughter
god it's so much different than when you
have a boy I'm now if your obvious again
of your boy go away with your creepy
uncle but you said as a dollar yeah it's
a different of course lightly the world
is different if you listen to like women
in your family who are older so my
mother-in-law my mother my wife the one
thing that they will tell you is I don't
give a [ __ ] with it my daughter is never
watched by a male
babysitter and like like a teenage boy
or cuz I don't care if he's a eunuch I
don't care who what it is
speaking of getting molested check this
out and we all know your history of
molestation and I celebrated I actually
made you the man you are demand I answer
that dude that wanted you to [ __ ] them
in the ass I celebrate the guy that camp
counselor tried sucking your dick god
bless you sir because you made Brian the
kid counts right check this out though
I mean why I ran way too far yesterday
my by [ __ ] body was killing me I'm
like I need massage so bad and our boy
Todd is like eight there's this app we
can get masseuse
yeah comes your house and I'm like is it
legit like I don't need some hot asian
lady come over jacking off in front of
the family you know
so I gone that I seriously he has like
60 stars recommendations the pictures a
little blurry from my cow eye you know
how but she's this good you know it's
just I can be a dime piece put the kid
down at 7:30 masseuse comes already ate
this chocolate beauty the door really
yes this could dive a dime pit don't
[ __ ] dream that I have I mean this
could dive a chocolatier diabete what
boobs on into the rib why is a big old
table ready to do work I throw it
smelling like it smelling like candy
I'll smell like pure butter lotion ah ah
a little coconut a lot of chocolate so
it smell like chocolate and
possibilities got to get tropical up in
the edging not trouble this about to get
Africa oh so she comes in where's Peter
shot with the bongos what I [ __ ]
never loves are locked
you can be my my my my my my mama this
chocolate angel masseuse comes to the
door I'm like you're you pictures blurry
on the app and then just she goes ah god
I want creeps hit me up to the way I
looked I'm not showing the best masseuse
you know there isn't yeah no doubt ah so
she I'm like you know set up here in
front of - yeah let me watch the baby
sets off and why yeah like kids upstairs
okay
and should what do you want me to watch
I put on Love & Hip Hop so racist I was
like anyway Judas under drinker she's
all know not as maybe an Epsom salt bath
you know I got nervous of the guy and
then the whole time then I go you're
like wow I'm ready I'm in for now I'm
like yeah yeah I don't know I've never
done it the house do do I wear shorts or
chocolate sweats or I can wear ski
outfit I don't know what the [ __ ] to
where I was going across the line yeah I
don't know what you should wear full ask
my outfit so you can't see me this
raging boner so she's like oh you can
just take everything off I'm like ah ah
you're not wearing boots Boyle oh dude I
wear a thin sheen of oil and you never
attack ties a bad idea isn't do you guys
too long cause it's been really all
broke right yeah blood aesthetic zilean
ah ah turn your goddamn the strong I
like my neck outside let me look at me
yeah this happens income from hooters
how are you doing here so I [ __ ] I go
I put on shorts on like this just yeah
he really home yeah let's put on the
shorts oh I left some baggy shorts on
how'd your dick down with a whole circle
piece of leather writer strap
I just I was just trying to thing about
Amy I really a much you're taking the I
thought about breaking down Kovalev ward
in my head I just got to run dogs
there's no stand around on one let's
talk about the busy weekend Pikachu you
say there's amazing massage there's a
beast she worked it super beast yes when
you turned over and there was a tent
going on when you were doing the old
Nazi salute happened nope I went deep
into my [ __ ] zero dark thirty
training deep into it deep and that
thing was snooze yep snooze oh is like a
snail yeah what if she even gets I want
to set a fencer she's like this mother
[ __ ] well cuz it's natural I feel
like when you get massage to get an
erection
well latter who would it be told is a
man I don't allow that man massage me
like dude is so struck now man mmm well
I've had a couple Russian guys work me
over but truth you have had I say advice
about Brooks
these giant hoods come in all fighters
all I do judo I kept one I told you that
sorry i sorry guys guy was [ __ ]
beating me up always sticks put honey on
yarn I'll just add that they put the
honey on out of these this guy had no
here you don't eat it
no stupid let's say wait a minute bro
honey you have one of those like Russian
Thai massage yeah my boss sure huh you
don't talk about Russian Taiwanese right
have Russian I wish that I know let's
like ever I don't get together and he
suspect mimics Russian with ice cold and
then they put hot hunt on you I haven't
I mean you sucked it what hey wait a
minute
I sent Brennan a picture of me where the
camera pans and I have just my dick out
of my pants like just so just Joyce's my
three-word just the three-piece
featherless bird stick and I wouldn't
hold the camera back and you know you
just see my dick I tended you sasso and
to Julia and I get from Brennan I go
what the [ __ ] bro and then I got let me
suck it and then I got ugh sorry my
iPhone that's all these stupid
autocorrect sorry the bliss the blood
did you all heard a man's like hey this
is weird but uh wait what are we talking
about oh yeah that your Russian massage
this guy this guy is massaging me with
his pale pink hands just comes in to
cook brought all that Russian body they
never smile just that big shoulders and
he can't relax and he's going like this
is he's massaging me going and I'm like
uh-uh
I miss is not be strong for you because
you're here not here and just like miss
I'm then I'm done and he's cowling off
and you know me how I take bodies in
yeah he's telling off like that and I go
were you a wrestler or something are you
trying to get [ __ ] and he goes you got
yeah quiets do your workout this is the
end of my you're lucky he's telling off
and he goes yes I do I do doodle I said
judo
I said thong did you compete he said yes
I have one gold medal from Jeezy's
kneeling pigs
I see he made a lot of smart decisions
in life could you massage my man I went
looking up he was I was massaged by the
Olympic gold medalist in judo and he's
at Brooke Mahajan it was yeah I mean he
was good I came out a new woman I can't
I can't as amazing
can't [ __ ] with men and being masseuse I
just can't do it dude I went so now is a
real problem sir Marina del Rey I don't
live there anymore but there's like
massage parlors there down badness you
know they're everywhere
yeah when you walk in I I do not know
this yeah now there's a thing called rub
max rug
rub rub max calm up Maps download maps
call Rosa nap oh I heard what they say I
don't have another guy of a friend told
me all right I collagen phone when i
some sort of creak yeah anyways when you
know in these plates I guess a sure sign
that they're gonna Jack you off which
I'm oh it's always awkward man like I
don't want some freaking giant he/she
exactly on what Skyy I need a good
massage man I put my body some Susan
beat sure I'm saying a lot of Buer sure
when you go in there it says this is a
serious place of business no happy
endings right I guess that's what kind
of like a honey dick sign that means we
do happy and we do have if you've been
there like you own a four-season a lot
of fun we don't do a banach wink wink
hey don't even ask unless unless you got
an extra hundred dollars dude it's
exhausting if you're not looking for
that I know an actor who's not the most
attractive man but a little bit famous
and he was sitting there waiting at
Verizon back when I had four eyes was
Silvo yeah and he was I see him at the
fries now I'm like hey let's call his
name Pepe I like hey hey they don't own
a Lovelace my code name all right Hannah
and I go how you doing he goes I'm good
and I go all right I go what are you
doing he goes well right there he kind
of uses doesn't even point this uses his
eyes he's right there I go where I go
there I go okay what the building next
story is mmm
best massage place there is and also
know what do you mean by that because
you don't look like an athlete I know
that's you don't have sore muscles
because you don't do any exercise ever
you guys oh but I'll make you think
they'll treat you like they love you
that's my favorite place and I know all
these places he was a real connoisseur
he do it all so here really rings is off
Wilshire in fact it [ __ ] was and I'm
not joking but excuse me utilize swear
to God like because I
a same fret not the same friend yeah
another friend who's in the business of
entertainment yeah and being on TV
also known as the tube to the youngsters
or he said the same thing goes there's a
place off Wilshire and he goes no I'll
get on all fours but melt me like a cow
well yeah I have a must and put their
digits in my hassle on it God God see
now that's not for hey I just want
goddamn a song about that so that I'm
not getting it all for free yeah you're
never going to get me squeamish but
that's too much information even for me
I felt sick I mean I'm not going to
lunch also I don't know how you get on
all fours like a milky like you're
40-something year old [ __ ] fatty pay
off see oh and some in the bud and some
fingers in your ass too well that poor
girl no I have money
I went man my [ __ ] neck is killing me
I want my necks killing me I'm looking
for like the best massage parlor I have
guys that I've worked with when I was
doing sports little too serious I need
the words calm and I can relax yes I got
you yeah and that's when it there's this
place dude I'll get on all four we're
not that good at Carlos we'll get it
I'll get on all fours man they'll jack
me off like the milk in a cow is I have
another one put her fingers of my sight
well how are you how would you even ask
that
excuse me I know you just begin okay I
want to go on force you know I think he
just does it yeah and we don't and I
knew jerk me off like like milk my dick
mark and then you what's your name
okay Tiffany whatever the [ __ ] I want
you to take Dylan fingers Dylan thank
these two figures I want you to
inhalations long as you go right I want
to go three knocks deep three knocks
deep and twist and really get it wrote
Allu the [ __ ] out of my dad in on my
butthole and you you milk me like you
owe that you owe you owe so many money
you pay me back in a pail of milk you
understand me
get to work and you step over here you
bring me over a bunch of grass I want
you to hold grass in your hand I will
ask next whatever to that grass village
of Phoenix ow yo I'm gonna chew that
grass to Ithaca
yeah and then I wanted you to brand me I
want you to brand me right on my [ __ ]
I need some test um yeah $75 that's
amazing please $75 you get all that milk
I don't want I'd rather pay 200 not
worried about being tree like a [ __ ]
cow right get this kink out of my neck
not actual ears all over the table
I really have not talked that person
since I don't blame you I'm not gonna
shake his hands going to get sushi
Gandhi roar yeah long to think about
that eel son splitting the goddamn rolls
I'm not eating around that guy either
catch something at this hard thing of
being milk let's piss very bad then
we'll go to this um why don't we get
into some current event so see what's
going on in the world here man it's
crazy world out there crazy world up
crazy world owes start off with some sad
news well the first sad news is that you
own a car accident last week he drove
his truck in front of a train a moving
train and since then he's just been in
the hospital and somewhat non-responsive
someone said that he was actually moving
his hands you know when after this her
eyes are open but he's got his hands I
heard that but this is the the most
recent one on us and that's how they
said he's not responsive [ __ ] Wow Wow
yeah so what exactly happened Cheney so
his truck that stopped on the train
tracks to my I told my brother go hold
up
you got hit by a train on train tracks
is there I'm not making me accusation I
don't but my first instinct was like
he's a suicidal thing because we're
great I thought of that it was great
wrong like when you like hear train it
comes from all the way down like you the
time yeah yeah yeah it's hard but do we
know but then my brother goes no he was
helping someone I didn't hear anything
about helping anyone I heard that's it's
they're still investigating to have no
idea what's going on other than they
know that he knew that there was a train
coming he knew that his truck what he
wanted his truck to be in front of that
train like he there's no other way
I'm not saying through sighs there's
foul play here but when I first I went
hold up train yeah but then I saw when
my brother cuz I went oh man I hope it's
not something dark like suicide
something like that that's where my
brain goes to here when the CT very real
at all do you know what that I'm not and
I love ma'am that's one most one of the
best people I've ever met my life so I
wish him nothing but the best and I'm
not saying this properly all I'm saying
is when I saw with God a train
CT truck
and then I guess my burgers you'd be
surprised how many people are injured by
trains of a year he was telling me we're
talking a little bit about because we
did that we did Kingdom yeah and if I
break the hooey
yeah and I talked to him about a guitar
I'm gonna see Frank tonight about that
but I talked to him about head and head
trauma and I said you you must worry
about that he said I do worry about it
you know I said I said you have memory
loss because sometimes you know he said
and I and what he said to me is he goes
I just want to be able to put my own
shoes on when I'm older geez it was like
it was like but he's such a humble guy
and I thought he's really worried about
that as well as a farmer and and he's a
him family man you talk about his kids a
lot he's just a great guy but to me when
they said he had significant head trauma
you know after all that fighting and
then that I was just like god dammit you
know and he loved his mom I hope he
comes out the real he's a real is a real
man I'm real glad he was a class act and
I take away all his accolades and
fighting is what you know he's on Mount
Rushmore and he's a guy who would say
mass before his meal right like we'd be
word sitting there eating and he not
only did these are little things that I
noticed like right before we meet he
puts his head down and he thanks God for
his food and then as I was done with my
plate and he was done with his plate he
he reached over and said you done with
that and took my plate and took my tray
and you know those little things those
little common curly I don't think
there's any foul play here right
I almost silly goose loves to laugh and
loves to play around and just you know
we don't know the thing but that's like
all I saw was train not huge car like
who the [ __ ] gets hit by a train and yes
exactly
and the police wrote there that for
whatever reason they wrote exactly he
drove his front directly and or his you
drove his truck directly in front of a
train like why would a cop say directly
in front we don't know we don't know
what goes on in a man's head I don't
know who knows maybe he didn't maybe was
in pain taser maybe he's texting maybe
who maybe thought he could beat the
trains I got [ __ ] out only for this
[ __ ] train and hit that skid it out
and got too late like there's a lot of
factors is he known as like a drink or
anything like that I don't know you know
I don't know well enough to know he's
drinking you guys have got a lot of guys
I could probably give you some I don't
have any history of DUI or anything like
I don't know and I've never heard about
it so yeah so it's still up in the air
so tragedy that that that's the most for
me like a guy who took a lot of risks
and a guy who you know that that sounds
like something with the train would do
right some I would do yeah like I think
Holland I'm gonna see how would I get
hit by train I'm like you know my god
I've had some close calls in my car
where I'm like others Lane murders I'm
gonna [ __ ] speed right by this guy
and I'm not gonna crash in the wall and
I came so close so close to dying it
wasn't even funny something with not
huge your wrist a your you do with best
fight a long time like I'll [ __ ] I don't
wait for this [ __ ] train I'm just
gonna go this kind of speed out and he's
like oh [ __ ] too late boom yeah that's
possible who knows what else you got
that's a [ __ ] bum urchin one more
bummer all right so Tim Hague who fought
for the FC he had a boxing match this
past weekend I think it was this weekend
and he got knocked out and then he was
in the hospital and then he passed away
from his injuries from a boxing match
did you know uh he fought two guys that
you fought
he fought who Krista sure uh and bad
Michonne like I saw down his on his
rectum weren't there um I did not know
him you know we've had I've been in the
same room or we've had quick discussions
with AH it's not fair to say I knew him
he his issue is I think he was one in
three in boxing he got knocked out a
month before sore a few months prior to
this for my understanding so he had no
business fighting in there I think you
finally got did I watch the whole video
where he lost his last fight yeah I mean
they should stop that fight a few times
the guy who's fighting nine you know
it's just this mismatch why Tim was
doing it who knows it's just another
[ __ ] bummer man yeah I may had a
commission there too right so it was
actually sanctioned and everything I'd
read something about Edmonton Commission
what they say I mean that there wasn't
it wasn't like of some random boxing
event somewhere it was it was a
commission fight you know suffering
eight career knockouts is a lot include
four within the past 22 months that's
see that's the issue so the a career of
knockouts is about two crazy guys like
there's a lot of guys who do this oh
it's what you signed up for but it's how
how current were they and how often did
it happen
to take long enough time to time off
it's gonna be way better for your brain
yeah but you know it sounds like you
fought right before this Wow sucks man
he had no other options do you know that
to do this [ __ ] boxing little sketch
in alright how about this one this is on
this is an Alabama a shark - shark swam
up right in the shore when people are
swimming and the way it looks is
actually pretty freaky a bull shark or
what el Bama want to [ __ ] with the bull
shark I down that is he boy I just saw
shark all right I'm gonna call I'm gonna
call them as a pro sorry okay check
right and I are we know some [ __ ] we'll
be able to tell you right now by its
swim patterns
look how closely gets my god damn and a
little shark a little bit Joshua that
they want that one in his face yeah
we're gonna have sushi tonight I think
that boys can really [ __ ] about that one
not laugh at that they are super close
though
other one was kind of big I don't want
we have that one that's something to say
yeah I had time to say I think had a big
old head on those who think I'm faster
from this point looks like a Thrasher
Brennan that's a good-sized fin now at
the badge it could be a black terror
yeah I'd have to know what water they're
judging from the way it's patterns and
the way it's swimming in an attitude I'm
gonna go black typically after new black
could be a white tiptoe couldn't ya tell
you when they are pretty black though
I'll stay black you also what you know
I'm not scared of a black tip yeah I
mean about you out to jump right not
watering [ __ ] [ __ ] some photos swam
Chelsea when I swam well buying tips
swam with him before
great white would have [ __ ] my pants
yeah what else she'd add a little great
wine oh god Alabama's got a lot of
people die all the time so this is a
crocodile tamer
in Thailand and he puts his head inside
the crocodile again and then they're mad
at the croc yeah again no [ __ ] check to
say cross not o Habib al [ __ ] did he die
I'll just show you the video real quick
let me get eyes it has to be died oh
yeah well maybe he's putting his head in
there right I love the sound it makes it
goes
and he's leaving it there for a while
usually sweat jog it out idiot so suck
it out of there the drop of the debt on
this tongue you gotta get out of there
okay it's so hard to watch
so that oh my god I get hurt now that
heart and shake them around you know
let's go lucky he's lucky didn't [ __ ]
swallow them whole usually like a piece
of hair lint or sweat draw with a
touches such as the tongue always I was
ah yeah I heard it was sweat fear
whenever something touches the tongue
that it triggers there yeah yeah of
course
stain well yeah cuz you had your head
and get your head in a Crocs mouth
everyone knows if your products what my
dick and a Hornets [ __ ] nest and I'll
stick it in that hole because usually
they're going to be like that's the bit
that's a big snake coming again is we're
gonna sting them does this say what
happened or no just couple I'm sure
maybe a yeah nothing not just couple
teaspoons that's you're pretty cool
things going on your face yeah yeah sure
that might say yeah but it does look he
helped rounded a little brain better
you're lucky he let you get away
oh man thanks it that's he got is a
death roll okay hold him to that murky
water to the left hooks obviously do do
I'll make your head right off
swallow it one more animal and a matador
was killed
yeah doing a bullfighting exhibit and
the reason why he died is because he
tripped over his cape when he was
walking backwards and then the bull
ended up goring him inside the thing was
his liver and lung ah you what you get I
hate when they kill these animals like
that I heard it's like a part of the
culture and all that I get that but for
pretty white boy looking in its so
[ __ ] up to see him stab these things
it's a tough one ah [ __ ] and that was it
that was it that was it got him right in
the [ __ ] yeah Oh got that
anus on the way out oh man it's awful
but also you switch you get a lot of
those guys Matadors get gored all the
time by the way all the time because I
can't the game you're playing yeah
it's like that with this Tim hate stuff
that's that's the price of the game yeah
yeah you're gonna be other what you
think people are going to die
looks like Michael felt you'll instead
if you
what yeah thank you that this is
literally what you sign up all matadores
all Matadors have been gored at least
once or twice in their career how many
how many times has he done this though
when you trip over the Cape like an
amateur yeah that is such an amateur I
say you're not allowed to like from now
you're not allowed to approachable in
Spain of on foot a fighting bull so when
you stairs a fighting bulls it that's
being used for fighting the law is
apparently you must approach it on
horseback or on bike or whatever they
can't see you walking because they want
the first time the bull sees a man it's
the first time they've ever seen anybody
so that they don't know your your
movements is interesting same because
they learn quickly as we do Leslie
because he'll kill you yeah I think it's
true you look that sounds like a pretend
legit though can you look up no no I
think it's true you not allowed to
approach in Spain there's a law that
does not allow you to approach a
fighting bull a bull it's going to be
used for fighting on foot because they
learn how you move let's say mmm my
mother told me this don't say anything
about it see if you can find it I'll
look for it after this now or don't
waste everyone's time yeah that's a
silly rule let's be no because they made
it sensible it at fifteen you I don't
believe in these stories and now I was
like Maui oh cool let me look my dad to
tell me stuff and you I'm like you well
that's not simply not true I'll google
it right now my visor on your mom's
toilet what miscounted
you know I yeah yeah yeah I'm also not
eight well I said okay I also know the
world kind of and I heard that when I
was eight and I've been I've been so
nobody ever sent out six you soon as
that came on your mouth on it god that's
and it came out of my mouth I was like
you know I wasted my time inches Spain
grants bullfighting protect there it
says yeah you're not allowed says not
Vicky Callum was right you got
approached move on to what Elsie right
hand um Bill Cosby yet a hung jury
during his rape case so now it's in this
trial yeah which I believe means if you
have a miserable you cannot be retried
for a Crim
all the same affair right yeah no double
jeopardy no double jeopardy so he got
off yeah so kernel trial well he's got
16 lawsuits pending but he's gonna pay
out the ass he's not gonna do prison
time it's not spared the one he's at the
back nine a decade behind bars and comes
at the end of a fifth year Wow do you
think he did it I do I think when
there's that much smoke there's got to
be fun five-o when small women or
whatever hey smoke ya know there's
[ __ ] 60 look like nine walls in place
yeah I mean you know it wouldn't that
many people are laying hey he drugged me
and had sex with me I am good at ready I
believe all of them yeah I mean I mean I
think some are exaggerating a little bit
I think all of them have some sort of
sexual I think internet war I think he
has a fetish and that is that he drugged
his wife in the head and had sex with
yes and he admitted I do think that
women doing that yeah for the past 40
years and get away with it I mean I I
just I did all those women didn't get
together I mean you know come on it's
very strange out of a friend go if he if
dude a few is white this will be a story
well no white or blacks on a rate
thinking one of the greatest comedians
maybe in some ways nobody will think is
one of the best ever like I I would even
make that argument you could even say he
might be with the best ever so when you
have somebody who's a genius comedic Lee
and oh by the way had one of the most
popular TV shows oh and by the way let
me add one more thing I think was the
first entertainer to make a billion
dollars so by the way still looks like a
burnt turtle that chef still for this
day looks like a burnt turtle without a
shell even though he's getting fat in
his old a region where laughing is
because it's that's 100% true it's very
offensive but it's 100% true if you do
not was anybody to anybody denies that
then you don't have a sense of humor and
you're lying to yourself
because that might be the greatest
description of any human being I've ever
heard but having said all that he looks
like a burlesque show and I want to make
a shirt this is it's him with it without
a turtle out show his hands crossed and
just covered in pills just on a pile of
pills
it says come at me brother or says
mister steal yo girl oh my god well he
ran a temple ran track a temple he
has his honorary PhD hopefully all that
so all that goes away so six all the
goes it goes away all the entire your
library your legacy your kids are no
everyone's kid now well you don't
mention Stassi York oh yeah his son was
murdered Internet - he's got two I think
two daughters who at least when they
were younger because I went to high
school one of them were beautiful and
that's what I think about like I was
there all [ __ ] when he thinks about
his daughters like and he faces them and
what's going on like why do I bet his
daughters don't they don't believe it I
think one of them wrote an essay about
how he didn't do it when she his wife
well how about he at the Taj Mahal yeah
he had all these side pieces and Corey's
like yeah it takes a long way I'm a bad
dude outside my meds I I [ __ ] around
with a lot of girls huh I apologize and
then his girl his white I feel sick
about them his wife's like yeah she's
ride-or-die
that's a ride-or-die woman and I admire
or she just like yeah I like waking up
in this mansion and [ __ ] do your thing
what do you think of that like what do
you think of a ride-or-die woman like
that does she have to believe that is
she she probably loves my Stephanie it's
probably too late now yeah
I bet she's younger she'd say flushes it
was well this is my this is my the man I
love and he is deeply flawed in one
aspect of his life what I gotta find any
flaw about that because I don't know how
I mean think about Bernie Madoff his but
one son died of cancer and his other son
hung himself um okay I don't know how
does how does his by the way I was
Bernie Madoff wife and the mother of
those two boys how is she doing I don't
know yet nothing to do with that I don't
know how it goes to I don't know like if
you've been right or die for so many
years just like [ __ ] man because because
I know the real bill this is the Bernie
Madoff his son stopped talking to him
his wife stopped talking to him they all
were like your scumbag we'll see you
later
you know I don't know man yeah what does
she go chin man where were you say I
mean on those it's Oh Bernie Madoff it's
obvious he did mess up yeah he admitted
yeah with this one they can kind of live
in a fantasy world like don't do it it's
so old please also like it is current
yeah I think there'd be you almost can't
look at it too closely or yo go crazy
I think you guys like
go crazy house come after my man for
money old school to like 70 what ya do
my thing in Sandy's yeah yeah
I don't know so old maybe I don't know
Wow alright so this is so brand-new that
I wanted to bring it up that UFC
officially stripped drained or enemy of
her title and then they're officially
booking cyborg vs. Megan Anderson for
214 no [ __ ] and Duran amis like she says
she didn't know why did you think was
gonna happen stripper she refused to
fight she refused fight cyborg won to
find out 35
she's at my goals number five 45 extra
35 her
I'm not fighting cyborg she's taking way
too many steroids I'm not fighting her
name she's like okay well that's the
Challenger so we're just going to strip
your belt and now Megan Anderson where
cyborg is the new fight at UFC one
are you sorry 214 Megan Anderson lose to
her enemy no less so me answer is new
she's from Invictus she's Invicta one
Australian training Denver dime piece
that's right skills to ring her up she
was bunch of sorry Larry yeah yeah I'm
glad they signed it you know i if anyone
didn't give cyborg a run for her money
at least a competitive fight it's gonna
be this girl she's you know she like
chicken box she's big enough to there's
a section a big girl yeah like she like
physically she hinders yeah she's able
to match cyborg a little bit and she's
really pretty so you know it makes sense
she's also a champ that it makes it it's
the most logical fight for sideboard
she's amazing but my only concern is it
you know this is a win-win for Megan
amount of watch you see us see it's a
huge card DC Cormier - cyborg for the
Bell everyone's watching
so as win or lose it's good for her as
long as she doesn't get starched like in
ten seconds is on if she makes it a
fight she'll be well known and then she
and work your way back into this and get
more publicity and hopefully they tell
her story just they need a girl like me
and Anderson bad right now alright just
hope it's not too much too soon about 45
she has come from
Invicta where she's the champ
she looks the part you know like yeah
that's how you want your chance ha ha
she real tall she's every bit like her
inside where did a faceoff at the summit
then she's she's not sure now 6 feet Wow
wow that's a big girl strong girl she
probably walks around what 170 easy so
those are good with tough to tell but
his biggest cyborg it's a great fight
man it's a good it's a you know the best
fight cyber attending a long time since
you fought that will champion more
touched Megan Addison's thing all around
her where she started good girl she's
good yes she's pretty well-rounded man I
like that fight and with duranta me
being like I can't believe they stripped
me what the [ __ ] did you think was gonna
happen
you have to fight you knew when you knew
the winner of ha leader enemy you knew
going into that the winner I would have
to fight cyborg because this be honest
you're just keeping that belt warm for
cyborg she can take that fight so they
made this [ __ ] vacant title interim
title up for you in Brooklyn you kind of
keyed your way to win that fight against
Holly now you won't fight cyber because
you say steroids and you want fight at
35 would you think there should do this
forever
how do you think this can end for you
who's your management and then you go
into hiding you don't address it forever
till now the [ __ ] you think UFC was
gonna do yeah this is the game what do
you think of that when he's you're the
worst champion of all time she wasn't
very liked I know especially with the
late punches to everything yeah
everything a punches and then and then
talking about she's an offended then I
guess cyborgs next oh my hand hurts and
she goes into hiding and then it was
your hand for a while and now she's on
steroids moans no she's not she mean you
saw has been all over here what are you
talking about you fight her no no no no
I'll lose that fights I'm not gonna
fight her I'm gonna fight 35 yes he goes
all right cool we had to something 45
pound belt no brainer not being mean she
[ __ ] this up so the UFC said that they
told they notified her and her team and
then she said that no they never even
told me at all does the UFC ever do that
oh yeah a hybrid of guys find out you
know when March minions fought lyoto
machida mark found out
like was watching something as like mark
means real cheese like what about [ __ ]
yikes Wow and that's how she said she
found out the same way she saw the media
I'm with the UFC here like what the [ __ ]
you think was gonna happen this yeah of
course we're a strip it we got announced
this cuz we're announcing make an answer
and Cyborg for the interim for the title
now but they can idle we're not waiting
for you you're the one I want to go mi
and I can social media not do interviews
forever like when she's not because I'm
not being a star
yeah the circus goes on this elephant
doesn't want to move cool we're gonna
leave you in [ __ ] Jeremy Germany with
a but yeah she the circus announcements
on keeping all good night Alice she
wanted out huh that's why feels like no
she said she wanted out but she knew
like what she thought they're gonna call
you and ask if it's okay come on man
it's way too cutthroat to deal with this
[ __ ] yep
what else you got you how about this one
crew she Tran the dime piece girl that
dated Chris Brown yeah she is granted a
five-year restraining order against him
so she can't go to Chris Brown no no I
Chris Brown's yeah can't get near her I
saw her at the Grove when I was there
the other day
bring her up for a sec dime piece really
she was a stripper correct I think you
were you saying that before choose his
stylist yes she's a stylist and then she
died women and that's how they met well
she's a yeah she wore Nicias
yeah she's because she worked so pretty
and what happened with them did he hit
her something else yes
he kept cheating on her the Rihanna back
and then she had abused him ever a
beating yeah no no Chris Brown had be
with someone else
hey and she was like that's the final
straw like he got some other girl
pregnant she accused him of hitting her
threatening hitting and all sorts of
stuff
letting the killer to right I don't know
but he's afraid yeah she sounds like
okay it sounds like a they they had a
volatile relationship
Wow five-year restraining order damn I
mean judges don't think take that
lightly she'd have to present evidence
right you have to present evidence oh
yeah she's just now coming out with him
hitting her cuz they did an interview
when they broke up I didn't say anything
she just said he cheated and he had
another you got another pregnant but now
she's saying that he hit her who hits
girls who in the world [ __ ] it to get
[ __ ] and why would you hit her I
don't know man oh I'll take some solid
punches Berger I'm not for just for the
buckle up I'll be your big old dummy I'm
not gonna hate you better your big
letters thank you where's my mean now
yeah you can get spanked does she know
in fact she's in fact I'm gonna get on
all this I'm gonna get all fours and
we're gonna play the cow game mmm
I don't know if she's into that well I
don't care that's your punishment you
got to count me up damn and now she said
to Chris had beaten her before someone
uh someone means to just beat the [ __ ]
out of this room didn't Chris Brown beat
the [ __ ] out of Rihanna and fighter it's
not an equal fight though okay she'll
get back at her you had that Rihanna
gives back it's not [ __ ] around
he loved that dude though he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude I'd step right and I'd be
like hey Chris I box pop pop pop pop pop
pop
I bet ready okay cry my chest for a
second but know what that what a like
Chris Brown is some frickin girl
good-looking guy and he can dance
no he's so terrible Brown to make a hit
very second I gotta be such a [ __ ]
like it'd be such a bad passionate bro
he's just pads on let's guess he gets
territorial over his girls and keeps
them in line
oh you wouldn't hand rough rule out
Johnny there's a price about a certified
domestic violence again laughs I am
definitely not I am definitely not
condoning that [ __ ] I'm having a virtual
bath house and then I'm saying that you
know a guy like that seems to get away
with this [ __ ] but now he's got a
five-year see he got a young you got a
little screwed with the whole Rihanna
thing but then it you so doubt this
current bounce pass yeah well I think
sometimes with people like this they're
like well you know with passionate
relationship and a lot of it was like
she accused him of it but there what you
know I mean you people will make excuses
for you you know what I mean for a while
but again it's like if there's that much
smoke after a while you're like oh sorry
you you hit women you know you know I'm
pretty passionate do i excuse doesn't
well now I don't hit girls no no hit
women so needs to be destroyed
yeah
done it Jen um how about one more all
right what do you think it is that 10%
of them this is during this is according
to a study with a thousand people online
I you know what I believe it so nearly
ten percent of American adults believe
chocolate milk comes from exhales it's
dead that seems a little suspect and
you're that dumb and we need you to glad
to move out of the country I saw some
Good Morning America - and it's dead
serious they're interviewing people in
their debts this I feel like we should
take those people in the back and just
like shooting you ever talked to police
officers and when they make arrests in
certain parts of this country and the
one thing they say is they go dude some
people are so dumb you would you would
[ __ ] fall over like in the majority
like you'll see you did this crime how
do you think we're gonna get away with
it well they're so [ __ ] Donna no
that's what I always said when feel I
told you hope your kids a professional
athlete he's an actor can mean what I
like I still wanna be dumb cuz you can't
dumb you can't teach like there's some
people just man their IQs are super low
and you have a conversations like
homicide detectives talking about how
she was driving this guy to the station
and he said what do you live and she
said near the airport he goes oh yeah so
what he did you fly to work then she was
like what he's like you flatter work
she's like no I Drive because okay then
why do you live near the airport well
because I just do now I have to take you
and put you in jail for the rest your
life obviously and that's exactly where
you belong so thank you so much for
playing but not this time around it's
time thanks for playing life Union lost
thanks Widow I sort of need dumb [ __ ]
until you fly to work to Hamish it's a
lot of work no I don't why linear
airport after like you serious bro is
this a [ __ ] yo your turn to shine she
didn't he goes he goes what is alright
well obviously I told I told you that
was a long time goes by this kid from
Louisiana hell of a football player yeah
this time I see you we're scenarios
y'all y'all white boy I spell chair I
want this yeah can you imagine chair
blue that [ __ ] you knows how you
spell chairman could get serious yeah
that spell chair never did you get it
[ __ ] calling you public high school
college yeah you want to step it out
even if I can spell it right well got
his degree behind me of course there you
go it's football phobia Lee we're doing
this all programs Oh - oh my god you off
[ __ ] you've ruined my day how the [ __ ]
did you make it here so much my college
how are you not dead or in jail oh my
god I will fight I'll see on the other
side well Meredith yeah job knows about
stupid people I actually do and it's
interesting because this is about
something called confirmation bias and
this is kind of this is one of the I
think one of the big problems in all of
our lives and all of us do this so what
is confirmation back so you if you
listen to like a lot of like you know
debates you hear a lot of like so are
human beings responsible for global
warming does gun control make society
safer it's immigration a problem you
know is illegal immigration bad for the
economy there are all these questions
you always hear this stuff okay all
these complicated questions and what you
want to do when you're when you're kind
of listening to all these problems these
questions is Trump good it's Trump bad
for the economy is good for the
countries you go to the world you should
be the kind of person that is empirical
in your conclusions what does that mean
empirical evidence is when you have
measurable evidence when you have
evidence that is irrefutable or at least
measurable okay then you should be the
kind of person that changes their mind
it's okay to change your [ __ ] mind
politically it's okay to say maybe I'm
not as conservative maybe I'm not as
liberal as I thought I was based on the
evidence okay but people just don't do
that they don't usually revise their
beliefs in light of new information okay
and that's something that all of us have
a problem because what happens is our
feelings our feelings control our
thinking never underestimate how your
feelings
your belief structure how you arrays
that [ __ ] clouds the way you think so
just take a stock on that because all of
us all of us have what's called
confirmation bias okay and it's it's a
tendency psychologically the favor the
information that already confirms your
beliefs and how you think if you're very
religious and you see something happened
you're going to come up with a religious
reason for that and you're going to be
blind to maybe other explanations we all
do it it's very human no matter how
educated I do it we all do it so just it
the world would be a better place if you
first look at yourself and take a stock
on where you have confirmation bias and
you will be [ __ ] amazed
I've done it you'll be amazed of how how
much you suffer from it because we all
do your feelings control your thinking
you have fast responses to complicated
questions slow down step back slow down
and think think for a second and look at
the evidence I swear it'll make your
life better you'll make better decisions
you'll be a better person and you'll
probably end up making more money or at
least not losing a lot of money so there
it is that's my drop in knowledge for
you kids boom stand massage parlours
there it is stay out of the massage good
good Potkin get your towel on I enjoyed
this podcast good man I think we covered
a lot of important ground we sure did
I know you got a busy day busy Dave be
done by your comedy sexual thing yeah
sure we didn't talk about it yeah talk
tell us what's gonna at with what's
going on your how many Central County
Center on this is not happening which is
ari Shapiro my story very exciting I'm
shoot it tomorrow they should have
cheetahs oh I've been ochita strip guns
they sure that she does that's a great
place could call downstate yeah it's
around stage not used to around state
now why haven't you invited me it is
interesting if your humble firearms no
not all I hope you guys are the Oprah
Rhonda all right well yeah man about to
see you know this not happening I do not
know when it's going to air but I am
shooting the story it's official and
then I'm off big deal dude yeah that's
cool right really big deal I like that
story you're going to tell and then I'm
off to New York on Wednesday and then
Thursday have the big brown breakdown
live Gotham comedy club that [ __ ]
sold-out and Friday of do work for spike
Saturday's the big fight Massacre garden
and then I'm be doing bar stool out
there the podcast I'm be doing Jim
Norton's podcast ok
just a more stuff man so the ball is
rolling then I will be live I have a
bunch of dates coming up there just
announced and just give me the
finalization today I'll have for you
guys but the only date I have for you
right now not sold out its Phoenix stand
up live p5k dot-com where can I find
you'd be you know everybody I'm going to
be I just found out in Charlotte in
North Carolina of course you know I'm
going to be addy just for laughing but
Charlotte North Carolina July 22 the
22nd I'm going to be at the comedy zone
Charlotte North Carolina get your GAD
but take it son still yes at t fat K
I'll have that posted but we'll have it
up by tomorrow you did they just say
that's just yeah just not yet Charlotte
North Carolina the comedy zone Charlotte
look for buying countless tickets will
be available in the next few days as
always anything you ever need t fat K
calm this is the finally kid we're out
yeah